SCP-096, the Shy Guy, versus SCP-2599, the
reality bender named Zena Cho.
Who comes out on top in a confrontation between
these two incredibly powerful anomalies?
Let’s find out.
SCP-2599 is a 14-year-old girl who is incapable
of disobeying any command given to her, but
also incapable of successfully carrying out
that command fully.
She can come close, but never quite reach
the goal she is given, which can allow for
some powerful reality-bending.
In a test, 2599 was told to neutralize 096,
and she maneuvered and outwitted SCP-096’s
frenzied rage state, landing a few hits on
the entity.
But with 096 being as terrifyingly relentless
as he is, 2599 only reached the halfway mark
in her execution She came incredibly close
to neutralizing the entity, but in the end,
her anomalous nature demands that SCP-096
undeniably comes out on top.